Prince Harry and Megan Markel are using
their tour of Australia to bring
attention to causes close to their
hearts the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
spent time with surfers focused on
mental well-being on Sydney's famous
Bondi Beach Harry then climbed 464 steps
to the top of the iconic Sydney Harbour
Bridge been there to kick off the
Invictus games Jonathan Vigliotti is
following the couple in Sydney Jonathan
good morning to you and good morning
Prince Harry started the Invictus games
to help raise awareness for injured vets
and this evening you can see the iconic
sin the Opera House lit up in
celebration eighteen countries including
the US will be participating and this
afternoon the Prince took some pretty
extreme steps to raise awareness it took
13 minutes for the Prince to summit
Sydney's Harbour Bridge where he
launched the fourth Invictus games in
the skies over the city he started the
athletic event in 2014 for injured and
sick servicemen and women around the
world it's one of 76 engagements Prince
Harry and Megan are expected to attend
during a whirlwind 16 day tour of
Australia Fiji Tonga and New Zealand the
couple's already been welcomed with open
arms for some it's been too much to
handle this royal mania reached a fever
pitch after the announcement that Harry
and Megan are expecting a baby earlier
today the parents-to-be arrived
hand-in-hand at Sydney's Bondi Beach
where shoes came off along with the
formality that usually defines these
royal events they sat in the sand with a
surf group that gathers here weekly to
discuss their personal struggles this is
meant to be one of the more intimate
moments of the trip so far the royal
couple choosing Bondi Beach as the
backdrop to discuss mental health a
topic important to both of them Harry
has been very vocal about dealing with
the death of his mother Princess Diana
he opened up on the beach about the role
Megan has played Harry talked about the
fact that he
it's been a long time trying to find
someone to talk to to have those
conversations around mental health and
and it was really beautiful because they
found each other
surfer Sharla Connell also spoke to
Megan about how she stays healthy she
said for her it's yoga so being on the
mat for her is like being in the ocean
for us and at 4:30 a.m. this morning she
got up into yoga yoga 4:30 in the
morning you call that commitment or
perhaps just jet lag
tonight the couple is back here in the
city getting ready for the opening
ceremony tomorrow
Nora Yoga is good Jonathan Vigliotti in
Sydney thank you I think so much of what
Prince Harry does and now with Megan is
good he brings the celebrity focus that
comes to him and he shines a light on
other things like mental health issues
veterans with disabilities with the
Invictus games and he's so incredible
about sort of using that celebrity in
the right way uses a celebrity for good
but I love that young girl's reaction oh
my god hug me you know what that's like
John yeah the way I feel being near you
yeah sure Pinocchio but I love the
effect that they both have on people
your boy yeah I love that